[Music]
thank you so much for coming out tonight
raise a glass and toast to All of You
Beautiful People
cheers Anna said there was a man
outside he follow me home from with
brave get away from the
window
[Music]
you all
right it's amazing he didn't catch the M
well I haven't been sick in years you
just got lost a minute ago no I didn't
get lost listen I apologize if I made
you feel uncomfortable the other night
it's fine it's not fine my uncle talks
about you a lot my dad and I were maybe
thinking you could care for him during
the day all you'd have to do is be there
and go on walks and
stuff why did you follow me home from
the party
or do you only remember when it's
convenient I don't
[Music]
remember you don't know what you're
doing you're not able to make rational
decisions right
now why did you leave things were just
getting
complicated what do you mean
why did you and mom stop talking when
your mother was your age I she was out
of control no was
me really
[Music]
are hi welcome back the usual for you oh
yeah what's the
usual I don't know
you no do you remember her
[Music]
no